- [Narrator] Beginning as a friendly wager
between Shell engineers in the 1930s
about who could travel furthest
on the least amount of fuel,
the Shell Eco-marathon has grown
to become a hub of
technological innovation
for generations of students
who are challenged, inspired
and supported by Shell
to dream up
ultra-energy-efficient vehicles.
(whistle blows)
- My name is Benjamin Esquirol.
I am a part of the
Sask. Eco-marathon Team.
- Saskatoon, yeah!
(upbeat inspiring music)
- [Narrator] So, you've
been inspired to create
an urban concept vehicle
for the Shell Eco-marathon?
Well, according to the team
at Saskatchewan Polytechnic,
you will need the following ingredients:
a lawn chair,
a dismantled drill,
a 3D printer
(choir singing) and some inspiration.
- Throughout my childhood,
I would play hockey games,
and now that I'm older and in school,
during my spare time,
I referee hockey games.
(upbeat music)
I joined the team.
They put me on the frame crew.
I didn't know what to
make the frame out of.
Andrew explained to me, he's like,
"I have an idea, crazy idea.
"You wanna hear me out?"
And I was like, "Sure."
"What do you think of hockey sticks?"
- Carbon fiber hockey sticks.
- Hockey to Canada is the
national sport we wish we had.
("O Canada")
Because Lacrosse is the national sport.
(music screeching)
(light upbeat music)
- With the Shell
Eco-marathon the goal is to
reduce your energy consumption
as much as possible.
We want to be responsible
with the resources we've been given.
Repurposing the hockey
sticks, the water bottle,
the body shell itself
is a recyclable plastic.
- We came in with no expectations.
Actually my expectation was
to go around the track once,
and I would've been extremely happy.
(car revving)
(light upbeat music)
The atmosphere at Shell
Eco-marathon is awesome.
Everyone is interested in what you do.
Everyone is very friendly and open.
I would recommend anyone to come
who has an open mind and wants to learn.
(light upbeat music)
Every vehicle that competes
is completely different.
(cheering in foreign language)
Well this whole experience
is kind of life-changing.
Until I was on the plane in London,
it just didn't seem real.
They are looking for teams to come forward
with new ideas and see what young kids
have in their minds, right?
We make the future, right?
It's pretty cool.
(ding)